vamos a dar inicio a nuestra revista de
prensa hoy también en Estados Unidos
porque las reacciones en los editoriales
de los medios tras el anuncio de Joe
biden de presentarse a la reelección no
se hicieron esperar y por ello salud en
el estudio a Marta Moya Marta bienvenida
Buenos días Andrés Marta iniciamos con
lo que dice el Washington post sí Andrés
vamos a destacar el editorial del
Washington post que titula vaiden tiene
razón todavía estamos peleando una
batalla por el alma de Estados Unidos
dice que baiden cuando se presentó en
2020 hizo esta alusión a que estaban
librando una batalla por el alma de
Estados Unidos y que esta sigue vigente
según este editorial del Washington las
elecciones de 2024 se van a leer en
clave de referendo sobre Quiénes son y
quiénes quieren ser los estadounidenses
dice textualmente el editorial el
presidente baiden Ha logrado mucho pero
derrotar a Trump fue el logro que
definió y marcó el rumbo de su
presidencia además vai tiene que
demostrar dice esta editorial que es el
antídoto contra el extremismo y tiene
que defender sus logros bipartidistas
algo que ahora está difícil cuando los
republicanos tienen el control de la
cámara de representantes y además dice
esta editorial tiene que aprovechar su
posición en la casa blanca para ser
líder también en política exterior Marta
también hubo reacciones desde el
Washington Times el Washington Times
dice Por otra parte otro editorial que
titula di que no es así show
textualmente dice a una edad a la que la
mayoría de los políticos estadounidenses
viven cómodamente la jubilación biden de
80 años está listo para pugnar por
cuatro años más en la casa blanca dice
que biden se presenta a esta candidatura
para las elecciones de 2024 con unas
encuestas que contra Donald Trump le
salen a favor textualmente nos educaron
para creer que el servicio público es
una vocación noble y con las encuestas a
favor
empañar un poco esa idea Marta
precisamente una de las críticas más
recurrentes a la decisión de biden de
una reelección es su avanzada edad ya
que de ganar un segundo mandato
terminaría su periplo político con 86
años y estas críticas están reflejadas
en múltiples caricaturas muéstranos así
es y vamos a empezar Andrés con el Times
este periódico británico con una viñeta
del mítico Peter Brooks en la que vemos
el escudo de Estados Unidos y al
presidente Joe biden disfrazado como el
águila calva que es este emblema de
poder y de valores en el país pero vemos
a la águila con un andador y que en el
título de ese escudo dice no corriendo
por la presidencia sino arrastrando sus
pies Por otra parte hemos destacado
también tres viñetas de Cartoon cartoon
movement la primera es de la
caricaturista taiwanesas tellina Chen
que titula despacho Ball A prueba de
biden entonces vemos el escritorio de
con solo una silla de ruedas un gotero
de suero y un bastón tirado en el suelo
la segunda viñeta que destacamos del
cartoon bookman es del alemán que es una
imagen muy gráfica de Joe biden que hace
ese juego de palabras con parque
jurásico y titula llorassic Park Y por
último hemos destacado el bañetista
Alemán Marcus grollek con una viñeta que
muestra esa polarización en Estados
Unidos con Byron y Trump los dos con su
respectivos andadores portando los logos
de cada uno de los partidos demócrata y
republicano y a biden que dice mientras
que tiene que él acabar ese trabajo que
es el lema que empleó ayer para lanzar
su campaña Trump ya emplea su clásico
hacer América grande otra vez un tema
que ha dado espacio para el humor Marta
y no solo en la prensa gráfica sino que
ayer el partido republicano tampoco se
quiso quedar atrás y criticó a biden y
lo atacó utilizando la Inteligencia
artificial como es eso sí Andrés
que quedar atrás con las críticas a
biden tras el anuncio a la candidatura
de la reelección y emplearon un artículo
un artículo un vídeo con Inteligencia
artificial en el que decían
escenarios hipotéticos que pueden pasar
si vaiden gana textualmente
el presidente más débil de nuestra
historia y se imaginan escenarios como
la invasión china Taiwán la bancarrota
económica el descontrol fronterizo o la
violencia descontrolada en el país
veamos Este vídeo de los republicanos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un estilo muy particular del partido
republicano pero también que resulta
polémico ya que la Inteligencia
artificial ha generado mucha
desinformación y sobre todo en este
contexto de Cara a unas elecciones
presidenciales en Estados Unidos bien
Marta vamos a cambiar de tema porque
tras la conclusión de la Cumbre sobre
Venezuela ayer en Bogotá los medios
hacen su análisis sobre conclusiones de
este encuentro empezamos entonces con lo
que dice voice of America sí Andrés el
voice of America hace una especie de
análisis con expertos que resumen un
poco las conclusiones de esta Cumbre
internacional celebrada ayer en la
ciudad de Bogotá las conclusiones que el
canciller colombiano Álvaro Leiva son
primero la celebración de elecciones
segundo los pasos acordados tienen que
ir de la mano del levantamiento de las
sanciones y tres la retoma de los
diálogos en México entre el gobierno y
la oposición también dice este análisis
que lo que deja la Cumbre es devolver a
Venezuela al a la primera línea de las
prioridades regionales respecto a las
sanciones dice que Estados Unidos tiene
que ver que Venezuela celebra elecciones
y Venezuela tiene que ver que Estados
Unidos levanta las sanciones por lo
tanto alguien va a tener que ceder el
proceso todo este se puede ver empañado
primero por la fragmentación de la
oposición por las elecciones
presidenciales en Estados Unidos y
también por la complicación de los
diálogos entre gobierno y oposición
vamos a ver qué dicen entonces fuera del
continente el diario El País por ejemplo
el diario El País titula que la cumbre
celebrada en Bogotá tenía muchas
expectativas pero escasos resultados
textualmente dice si es difícil que 20
países se pongan de acuerdo en que lo
hagan sobre Venezuela y en unas tres
horas parece Misión Imposible además
dice que algunos de esos países que ayer
estuvieron presentes ni siquiera
firmaron un documento conjunto con estos
tres puntos sino que fue una decisión
unilateral de Colombia vamos a cerrar
hoy con a yasira porque recoge las
conclusiones de un estudio que destaca
que la Unión Europea debería proteger
más la libertad de prensa ante los
crecientes silenciamientos a periodistas
sí Andrés y nos referimos a un estudio
del comité para la protección de
periodistas que dice que aunque la Unión
Europea ha apoyado las leyes de la
libertad de prensa a lo largo de los
años El Progreso la búsqueda de las
soluciones sostenibles ha sido lento 10
países de la Unión Europea están a la
cabeza de la libertad de prensa pero el
entorno se ha hecho más hostil en los
últimos años amenazas online asesinatos
a una periodista maltesa en 2017 a otro
periodista polaco en 2018 los 10
periodistas que han muerto en el primer
año de la guerra en Ucrania el acoso de
los poderes fácticos todo ello dice este
comité para la protección de los
periodistas que son amenazas que
enfrentan los periodistas en Europa y
que la Unión Europea debería proteger
más la libertad de prensa no solo en la
Unión Europea sino también fuera y dar
protección a aquellos periodistas
refugiados que piden asilo dentro del
bloque comunitario Marta Moya con el
repaso de lo que dicen los medios de
comunicación Muchas gracias gracias